it was not far from here that morgan
wallen got into hot water for using a
racial slur
and now the country star sits down for
his first interview
about that disturbing incident
i went and checked myself into rehab for
30 days
you know just trying to figure out why
i'm acting this way
do i have an alcohol problem do i have a
deeper issue
[Applause]
[Music]
almost six months after the country star
was caught on a doorbell cam
calling a friend the inward wallen
followed up his apology
i let so many people down with the gma
sit down
they're gonna be a lot of people who are
gonna watch this interview and say he's
only sitting down because he wants to
clean up his image
it's all a performance i understand that
you know i understand that that
i'm not ever going to make you know
everyone happy
i can only come tell my truth what made
you think that the word was ever
appropriate
to use i i'm not sure
i think i think i was just ignorant
about it in our minds it's playful you
know i don't i don't know
if that sounds ignorant but that's
really where it came from
and and it's and it's wrong wallen's
album downloads actually spiked
nearly 500 percent after the video
leaked
in fact morgan who says he donated half
a million dollars to black charities
is the best-selling overall artist in
the u.s
so far this year
i'm torn about what message it sounds it
was a good album
varieties chris wilman who reports on
music breaks down
how morgan benefited from the
controversy it did get that weird extra
boost
when radio stopped letting him people
said okay we're going to show them
we're going to stream this even more you
know the people out there were making a
statement